hoy una evacuación forzada la región de
done jets en el este de ucrania comienza
las labores de desalojo luego del
anuncio del presidente volodymyr
selenski quien pidió a la población
civil que resiste a los ataques de las
fuerzas del kremlin abandonar la zona
marina fabrice tuvo que despedir a sus
padres que abandonaron el hogar familiar
que habían compartido durante siete
décadas tras el adiós no pudo contener
las lágrimas fue muy difícil tomar la
decisión supongo que será la última vez
que los vea es muy duro es necesario
irse pero dónde debe irse a la gente por
ejemplo si me voy y no tengo dinero no
puedo vivir en una estación de tren la
gente vive en las escuelas nosotros
decidimos quedarnos el verano todavía se
siente en ucrania pero pronto llegará el
frío y los más de 350.000 residentes de
la región de doñetsk son susceptibles de
quedarse sin calefacción electricidad e
incluso agua potable para algunos el
verdadero problema no es el invierno
sino los bombardeos he preparado
suficiente madera para calentar la
estufa en invierno así que no me importa
la calefacción lo que importa son los
misiles que caen del cielo todo tiembla
dentro de mí al mar ya estuve sola todo
el día ayer puede volverme loca el
martes llegó el primer tren al centro
del país lo que confirma el principio de
lo que las autoridades describen como un
esfuerzo de evacuación obligatoria que
sacará de donets a más de 200.000
personas para los meses de otoño
motores o fotos los rusos se acercan
desde las direcciones de crematorios y
back nut y el peligro para la vida es
cada día mayor además nos han dicho que
no tendremos calefacción tenemos agua
sólo unas horas al día y a veces ni eso
estamos sin agua durante dos o tres días
seguidos podríamos soportarlo nuestras
abuelas se quedaron pero tenemos que
irnos por nuestros hijos
antes de la evacuación una sirena aérea
perforó el aire evidenciando que la
guerra está lejos de acabar en el este o
craneano